the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so this big MIT I just came from a
faculty terrific faculty member Andy low
in in the Sloan School and I have to
tell you what he told us and then I had
I had to leave before he could explain
why it's true but this is like an
amazing fact which I don't want to
forget so here you go this is everything
will be on that board so it's it's it's
an observation about us or other people
maybe not us but so suppose you have a
biased coin maybe you don't the people
playing this game don't know but it's
75% likely to produce heads 25% likely
to produce tails and then the player has
to guess for one flip after another
heads or tails and you get a dollar if
you're right you pay a dollar if you're
wrong so you just want to get as many
right choices as possible from this coin
flip that continues so what should you
do well what I guess I hope we would do
is we would not know what the
probabilities were so we would guess
maybe heads the first time tails the
second time heads to the third time and
so on but the actual result would be
mostly heads
so we would learn at some point that
maybe maybe not quite as soon as that we
would eventually learn that we should
keep guessing heads right and then we
would be that would be our optimal
strategy to guess heads all the time but
what do people actually do they do start
like this same way and then they're
beginning to learn that heads is more
common so maybe they do more heads than
tails but sometimes tails is right and
then after a little while they maybe see
that it's yeah or they're just well
maybe they're not counting they're just
like operating like ordinary people
and what do ordinary people actually do
in the long run you would say guess
heads every time right but they don't in
the long run people and maybe animals
and whatever guess heads three-quarters
of the time and tails one quarter at a
time isn't that unbelievable they're
guessing tails a quarter of the time
when the odds are never changing anyway
that's that's something that economists
and and other people have to explain and
if I had been able to stay another hour
I could tell you about the explanation
but anyway that's that's I I see I've
written that on a board that I have no
way to bury so it's gonna be there and
it's not the subject of 1806 five but
it's kind of amazing right so there's
good math problems everywhere okay can I
just leave you with what I know and and
if I learn more I'll come back to that
question okay
please turn attention this way right
Norm's a little a few words on norms
just like that should be a word in your
language and so you should know what it
mean and you should know they're a few
of the important norms again a norm is a
way to measure the size of a vector or
the size of a matrix or the size of a
tensor whatever we have or a function
very important the norm would be a
function like sine X from zero to PI
what would be the size of that function
well if it was two sine x the size would
be twice as much so the norm should
reflect that but so yesterday or
Wednesday I told you the so there P
equals to 1 actually infinity and then
I'm gonna put in the zero norm with a
question mark because you'll see it's
that it has a problem but let me just
recall from last time so these are the P
equal to two is the usual sum of squares
square root usual length of a vector P
equal one is this very important norm so
a we call that the l1 norm and we'll see
a lot of that that really I mentioned
that it plays a very significant part
now in compress sensing it really was a
bombshell in signal processing to
discover and in other fields to to
discover that some things really work
well work best in the l1 norm the
maximum norm has a natural part to play
and we'll see that or its matrix analog
so I didn't mention the l0 norm all this
LP business so the LP norm
or for any P is you take the piece power
to the piece power up here P was 2 and
your take the piece root so maybe I
should write it to the one over P that's
then that way
taking piece powers and piece roots we
do get the norm of two V has a factor
two compared to the norm of V so P equal
to 2 you see that we've got it right
there P equal one you see it here
because it's just just sum of the
absolute values people infinity if I if
I move P up and up and up it will pick
out you know as I increase P whichever
one is biggest is going to just take
over and that's why you get to max norm
now there's zero norm where I'm using
that word like improperly as you'll see
because if so what is the 0 norm it's
the so so it's the number of non-zeros
of nonzero components its it it's the
thing that you'd like to know about in
question of sparsity does the is there
just one nonzero component or there 11
are there 101 like what that you might
want to minimize that because sparse
vectors and sparse matrices are much
faster to compute with you've got good
stuff but now i claim that's not a norm
in the number of 0 nonzero components
because what's the norm of to how does
the norm of 2v compare with the norm of
V the 0 norm it would be the same to V
has the same number of non-zeros as
so it violates the rule for a norm so I
think with these norms and all the peas
in between so actually the the math
papers are full of let P be between 1
and infinity and because that's the
range where you do have a proper norm as
we will see I think the good thing to do
with these norms is to have a picture in
your mind the geometry of a norm is real
is good so the picture I'm gonna suggest
is plot all the vectors let's say in 2d
so two dimensional space or two so I
want to plot then the vectors they have
V equal one in these different norms so
let me ask you what so here's 2d space
r2 and now I want to plot all the
vectors that have the ordinary l2
lengths equal one so what does that
picture look like I just think a picture
is really worth something it's a circle
thanks it's a circle it's a circle this
circle is that's the equation of course
v1 squared plus v2 squared 1 so that I
would call that the unit ball for the
norm or whatever is is a circle okay now
now here comes more interesting what
about in the l1 so again tell me how to
plot all the points that have V 1 plus V
2 equal 1 what what what's the boundary
gonna look like now it's gonna be let's
see well I can put in a certain number
of points there one and there one and
there at minus one and there
this one there was that would be the
vector that would reflect the vector 1 0
and this would reflect the vector 0
minus 1 so yeah ok so those are like
four points easy to plot easy to see
that the l1 norm but what's the full
what so what's the rest of the boundary
here it's a diamond good it's a diamond
it's we have linear set equal to one up
here in the positive quadrant
it's just V 1 plus V 2 equal 1 in the
graph of that is a straight line so all
these guys this is all the points with V
1 plus V 2 equal 1 and over here and
over here and over here so the unit ball
in the l1 norm is a diamond and that's a
very important picture it reflects in a
simple very simple way something
important about the l1 norm and the
reason it's just exploded him in
importance let me continue though what
about the max norm the Max or V infinity
what so again let me plot these guys
these guys are certainly gonna be in it
again they're zero
you know the plus or minus I and plus or
minus J that are good friends what's the
rest of the boundary look like now now
this is this means max so what what are
the rest of the points you see it does
take a little thought but then you get
it and you don't for forget it ok so
what's what's up I'm looking so suppose
the maximum is V one
I think you're gonna go I I think it's
gonna look like that out - out - one
zero and up to zero one and up here the
vector would be one one point for
something so the maximum would be one is
that okay so so so somehow what really
sees as you change this number P you
start with people one or daimond and it
kind of swells out to be a circle at P
equal to 2 and then it kind of keeps
swelling to be a square at P equal
infinity that's a that's a interesting
thing and yeah now what's the problem
with the 0 norm where are the points
with one non zero so so so I'm plotting
ball where are the where the where are
the vectors in this thing that have one
non-zero not not zero nonzero so that
that's not included and but I but so
what do I have
I'm not allowed the vector one-third
two-thirds because that has two non
zeros so where are the points with only
one nonzero yeah on the axes yeah that
does tell you so he can be there and
there okay without guy and of course so
is just keep going out so it totally
violates the you know so maybe the point
that I should make about these figures
so so like what's happening when I go
down to zero I'm served it really that
finger should be on the other end right
oh no shoot this guy's in the middle
this is a badly drawn finger l2 is kind
of a center guy l1 is the at one end el
infinities at the other end and this one
has gone off and the left there the the
diamond has yeah what's happened here as
that one goes down towards zero none of
these will be okay these these these
balls will or these sets will lose
weight yeah so they'll always have these
points in but they'll be like this and
then like this and then finally in the
in the unacceptable limit but none of
those this was not any good either this
this was for P equal half let's say sort
of uh that's a P equal to happen that's
not a good norm yeah so maybe the thing
you so there's a property of the circle
the diamond and the square which is a
nice math property of those of those
three sets and is not possessed by this
as this thing loses weight I lose the
property and then of course that's
totally lost over there do you know what
that property would be what what it's
for you concave convex convex I would
say convex this is true norm has convex
uni-ball maybe maybe for ball I'm taking
all of these yeah so I'm allowing the
insides of these shapes so this is not a
convex set that set which I shouldn't
so not not convex would be this one with
and that reflects the fact that the oh
the rules for a norm are broken the
triangle inequality is probably broken
and that yep I think that's sort of like
worth remembering and then one more norm
that's natural to think about is so s as
in the Piazza question s does always
represent a symmetric matrix in 1806
five and now I'm gonna ask my norm is
going to be so I'm gonna call it the s
norm so asses up actually it's a
positive definite symmetric matrix F is
a positive definite symmetric matrix and
what do I do
I'll take V transpose AV s V sorry okay
what's our word for that the energy
that's the energy in the vector V and
I'll take the square root so that I so
that I now have the lengths of two if I
double V from V 2 to V then I get a 2
here and a 2 here and when I take this
square root I get a overall two and
that's what I want I want the norm to
grow linearly with the two or three or
whatever I multiply by but what is the
shape of this thing so what is the
what is the shape I'm gonna get a
picture like that so what is the shape
of V transpose s V equal one less or
equal one if s is a positive symmetric
positive letters tell us I'm claiming
that we get a bunch of norms when do we
get the l2 norm what what matrix s would
this give us the l2 norm the identity
certainly now what's going to happen if
I use some different matrix s this
circle is going to change shape I'm
gonna have a different norm depending on
s and a typical case would be s equal to
3 that's a positive definite symmetric
matrix and this this now I would be
drawing the graph of 2 V 1 squared plus
3 V 2 squared that would be the energy
right equal one and I just want you to
tell me what shape that is so that's a
perfectly good norm that you could check
all its properties they all come out
easily but I get a new picture a new
norm that's kind of adjustable you could
say it's a weighted norm weights mean
that you kind of have picked some
numbers sort of appropriate to the
particular problem well suppose those
numbers are 2 and 3 what shape is the
unit ball in this s norm it's in ellipse
right it's an ellipse and I guess it
will actually be so the larger number 3
well will mean you can't go as far as
a smaller number - I think it would
probably be an ellipse like this and the
axes axis lengths of the ellipse would
probably have something to do with it -
in the three okay so that's just now you
know really all the vector norms that
are sort of natural to use these come up
in a natural way they're all as we said
the identity matrix brings us back to
the two norm so these are all sort of
variations on the two norm
these are variations as P runs from 1 up
to 2 onto infinity and is not allowed to
go below 1 okay that's norms and then
maybe you can actually see from this
picture here's our like somewhat hokey
idea of why it is that this norm
minimizing the so minimizing there or in
this norm so what do I mean by that here
would be a typical problem minimize
subject to ax equal B the l1 oh sorry
I'm using X now yeah one norm of the l1
norm of X so that would be an important
problem actually it has a name people
have spent a lot of time thinking of a
fast way to solve it it's almost like
least squares what would what would make
it more like these squares would be
change that to two yeah yeah can I just
sort of like sketch without making a big
argument here the difference between L
equal 1 or
to here yeah just I'll just draw a
picture now erase this ellipse but you
won't forget okay so this this is our
problem l with l1 it has a famous name
basis pursuit
well famous to people who work in
optimization for l2 it has an important
name well it's sort of like these
squares Ridge regression all sorts of
the this is like a beautiful model
problem among all solutions to ax
suppose this is just one equation like
c1 x1 plus c2 x2 equals some right side
B so the X's the constraint says that
the vectors X have to be on a line
there's suppose that's a graph of that
line so as among all these X's which one
yeah I never realizing what is what I'm
gonna say is gonna be smart okay I mean
not it's gonna be nice not gonna be
difficult
let's do the one we know best l2 so
here's a picture of the line let me let
me make it a little more tilted so so
you yeah yeah yeah like like two three
okay where this is the XY plane here's X
1 there's X 2 here are the pair of the
points that satisfy my condition which
one minimizes which point on that line
minimizes has the smallest l2 norm which
point on the line has the smallest l2
norm yeah you're drawing the right
figure with your hands the smallest l2
norm L to remember is just how far out
you go
it's it's
circular here so it doesn't matter what
direction they all giving the same l
2-norm it's just how far so we're
looking for the closest point on the
line because we don't want to go any
further we want to go a minimum distance
with two now so if so where's the point
at minimum distance yeah it's just show
me again once more with hands or
whatever it'll be that I didn't want
45-degree angles there I'm gonna erase
it again and really this time I'm gonna
get angles that are not 45 all right
brilliant got it okay that's my line
okay and what's the nearest point in the
l2 norm
here's the winner in l2 right the
nearest point everybody sees that
picture so that's the that's you know
that's a basic picture for for
minimizing something with a constraint
which is the fundamental problem of
optimization of neural nets of
everything really of life well I'm
philosophical so okay that's that's but
of course it always mean the question
always is and maybe it's true in life to
which norm are you using okay now count
and show with yourself that was the
minimum in l2 that's the shortest
distance where a distance means what we
usually think of it as meaning but now
let's go for the l1 norm which point on
the line has the smallest l1 norm so now
I'm going to add the two so if this is
some point a this is some point a zero
and this is some point zero B right
there
so those two points are obviously
important and that point we could figure
out the formula for
because it's we we know what the
geometry is but I've just put those two
points in so did I get a zero B yeah
that's a zero well so let me just ask
you that question
what point on that line has the smallest
l1 norm which has the smallest l1 norm
somebody said it just say it a little
louder so that you're wrong
tape forever zero B this point that's
the winner
this is the l1 winner and this was the
l2 the winner and notice what I said
earlier and I didn't see it coming but
now I realize this is a finger to put in
the notes the winner has the most zeroes
it's the sparse vector it's got a zero
well out of two components it didn't
have much freedom but it has a zero
component
it sits on the on the on the axes it's
the things on the axes that have the
smallest number of components so so yes
so this is the picture in l2 in in two
sorry the picture in two dimensions so
I'm in 2d and you can see that the
winner is has a zero component yeah yeah
and and that's a fact that extends into
higher dimensions too and that makes the
l1 norm special as I've said yeah is
there more to say about that example
that's for a simple 2d question that
really makes the point that the l1
winner is there it's not further you
don't go further up the line right
because because then you're then you
have even that's bad in all ways when
you go up further you're you're adding
some nonzero
first component and you're increasing
the non zero over second component so
your that's a bad idea
that's a bad idea this is this is the
winner and in a way here's the picture
yeah oh yeah I should prepare these
lectures but this one's coming out all
right anyway so this so the picture
there is the nearest ball it's at that
point and what is it can you see that so
that star is outside the circle this is
the l1 winner so and that's the nearest
that's the that's is the blow-up of the
l1 norm until it hits that's the point
where the l1 norm hit do you see it just
give it a little thought that that
another another geometric way to see the
answer to this problem is you started
the origin then you blow up a norm until
you get a point on the line that
satisfies your constraint and because
you were blowing up a norm when it hits
first that's the smallest blow-up
possible
that's the mint that's the guy that
minimizes ya just think about that
picture and I'll draw it better
somewhere - well that's vector norms and
then I introduced some matrix norms and
let me just say a word about those
okay word about matrix norm so so the
matrix norms were the so so now I have a
matrix a and I want to define those same
three norms again for a matrix and this
was two norm and what was the two norm
of a matrix well it was Sigma one turned
out to be so what that doesn't define it
or it could to find it just say okay the
largest singular value is the two norm
of the matrix but actually it comes from
somewhere so I want to speak about this
one first the tomb norm so so so it's
the two norm of a matrix and one way to
see the two norm of a matrix is to
connected to the 2 norm of vectors I'd
like to connect the two norm of matrices
to the two norm of vectors and how shall
I do that I think I'm going to look at
the 2 norm of AX over the two norm of X
so in a way to me that that ratio is
like the blow up factor if a was 7 times
the identity to take an easy case if a
is 7 times the identity what would that
ratio be yeah 7 if a is if a is 7 I this
this will be 7 X and this will be X and
norms the factor 7 comes out so that
ratio will be 7 okay
for me the norm is take that's the
blow-up factor when so here here's my
here's the idea of a matrix norm now I'm
doing matrix matrix norm from vector
norm and the answer will be maximum the
maximum of this ratio I call that ratio
of the blow up vector that's just a
made-up name the maximum over all X's
all the I look to see which vector gets
blown up the most and that is the norm
of the matrix
I know I've I've settled on norms of
vectors that's that's done upstairs
there now I'm looking at norms of
matrices and this is one way to get a
good norm of a matrix that kind of comes
from the two norm so there would be
other norms for matrices coming from
other vector norms and those we haven't
seen but the two norm is this is a very
important one so what is the maximum
value of this of that ratio for a matrix
a the claim is that it's Sigma 1 what a
big equality there now can we see why is
why is Sigma 1 the answer to this
problem I can see a couple of ways to
think about that but that's a very
important fact in fact this is a way to
discover what Sigma 1 is without all the
other Sigma's if I look for the X that
has the biggest blow-up factor and by
the way which X will it be which X will
win the max competition here and be
Sigma 1 times as long
Raja's as the the ratio will be Sigma 1
that'll be Sigma 1 when is this thing
Sigma 1 times as large as that for which
X naught for an eigenvector if X was an
eigenvector what would that ratio be
lambda but if a is not a symmetric
matrix
maybe the eigenvectors don't tell you
the the waiter the exact way to go what
so what vector view would you now guess
it's not an eigenvector it is a singular
vector and which singular vectors are
probably going to be you v1
yeah V one makes sense winner so the
winner of this competition is X equal V
1 the first the first right singular
vector and we better be able to check
that so again this maximization problem
the answer tells you is in terms of the
singular vectors so that's a way to find
this first singular vector without
finding them all and let's just plug in
the first thing of their vector and see
that the ratio is see what it see that
the ratio is Sigma 1 so now let me plug
it in so so what do I have I want a V 1
over length of V 1 okay and I'm hoping
to get that answer well what's the bout
of the denominator here the length of V
1 is what no big deal there that's one
what what's the length of the of the top
one so so
is a v1 now what is a v1 if v1 is the
first singular first right singular
vector then a v1 is Sigma 1 times u1
remember the singular vector deals were
AV equals Sigma u AV k equals sigma k UK
remember that so they're not
eigenvectors their singular vectors so
that's that is a v1 is the length of
sigma 1 u 1 and it's divided by 1 and of
course u 1 is also a unit vector so I
just get signal okay so that's another
way to say that you can find Sigma 1 by
solving this maximum problem and you get
that Sigma 1 ok and I could get other
norms matrix norms by by maximizing that
blow up factor in that vector norm I
won't do that now just to keep control
of what we've got now what were the what
was the next matrix norm that came in
last time very very important one for
deep learning and neural nets somehow
it's a little simpler than this guy and
what's the what was that matrix norm
what letter whose name goes here
Frobenius so capital F for Frobenius and
that and what was that that was the
square root of the sum of the all the
add up add all the a IJ squares for all
over the matrix and then takes a square
root and then somebody asked a good
question after class on Wednesday what
has that got to do with the Sigma's
because I my disappoint was that these
dorms are the guys that go with the
Sigma's that does that have nice
formulas for the Sigma's and here it is
it's the square root of the sum of the
squares of all the signals yes sorry let
me write Frobenius again but this
notation with an F is now pretty
standard and we should be able to see
why that number is the same as that
number yeah I could I could give you a
reason or I couldn't put it on the
problem set yeah I think it better on
the problem set because first of all
I'll get off the hook right away and
secondly this connection between in
Probie Nia so it's like a beautiful fact
about Frobenius norm that you add up all
the Sigma Squared's as M times n of them
because it's a all filled matrix or you
add up so another way to say it is we
haven't written down the SVD today's a
whoyou Sigma V transpose and the point
is that for the Frobenius norm actually
for all these norms I can change you it
doesn't change the norm so I can make
you the identity it's you as we all know
is an orthogonal matrix and what I'm
saying is orthogonal matrix you doesn't
change any of these particular norms so
suppose it was the identity same here
that could be the identity without
changing the norm so we're down to the
norm of the the Frobenius so what's the
Frobenius norm
of that guy what's the Probie Gnaeus
norm of that diagonal matrix well you're
supposed to add up the squares of all
the numbers in the matrix and what do
you get you get that right so that's why
this is the same as this because the
orthogonal guy there on the orthogonal
guy there make no difference in the norm
but that takes checking right yeah but
that's another way to see why the
provenience norm gives this and then
finally this was the nuclear norm and
actually just before the my lunch
lecture on the subject of probably about
a learning morning the lunch lecture was
about this crazy way that humans behave
not us but other humans other actually
well take that out of the tape yeah okay
anyway that was that lecture well before
that was a lecture for an hour plus
about deep learning by somebody who
really really has begun to understand
what is happening inside how does that
gradient descent optimization algorithm
pick out what what does it pick out as
that as as the thing it learns it's
gonna be the you know our goal in in
this course we're not there yet but his
conjecture is that that yeah so it's a
conjecture he doesn't have our proof
he's got proofs of some nice cases where
things commute but he hasn't got the
whole thing yet but it's pretty terrific
work so this this was professor cerebro
in Chicago so he just announced his
conjecture and his conjecture is that in
a model case the deep learning that
we'll learn about with a gradient
descent that we'll learn about to find
the best weights that the point is that
they're you know typical deep learning
problem these days there are many more
ways than samples and so there are a lot
of possible minima
many different weights give the same
minimum loss because there are so many
weights it's the problem is like too
many variables but it turns out to be a
very very good thing that's part of the
success and the he believes that in a
model situation that the optimization by
gradient descent picks out the weights
that minimize the nuclear norm so this
would be a norm of a lot of weights and
he thinks that's where the system goes
will see this this was comes up in
compressed sensing as I mentioned last
time so this but now I have to remember
what was what was the definition well do
you remember what the nuclear norm was
it's also his he often used he used a
little star instead of an end I'll put
that in the notes other people call it
the trace norm that's but I think this
end kind of gives it a name notation you
can remember so let's call it the
nuclear norm do you remember what that
one was
it was yes somebody's singing it right
add the Sigma's yeah just the sum of the
signals like you know one norm yeah this
is natural sort of l1 type of norm for
matrices
it's the l1 norm you have that Sigma
vector this would be the l2 norm of the
Sigma factor that would be the L
infinity norm notice that the vector
numbers infinity to 1 gets changed
around 2 when you look at the matrix
well so that's an exciting idea and it
remains to be proved people are
experimenting to see does it say is it
true
yep so that's a future yes okay so
that's today we've talked about norms
and this section of the notes will be
all about norms we've taken a big leap
in to comment about deep learning and
this is what I want to say the most and
I say it to every class I teach at the
near the start of the semester my
feeling about what my job is is to teach
you things or to join you join with you
in learning things as has happened today
it's not to grade you I don't spend any
time like like losing sleep y'all should
should that person take up one point or
epsilon penalty for for turning it in
for minutes late
hello with that right we've got a lot to
do here and so anyway we'll get on with
a job so homework three coming up and we
be using the notes that you already have
posted in stellar four for those
sections eight and nine and so on and
we'll keep going on Monday okay see you
Monday and have a great weekend
you